قال دومينيك كامينغز ، كبير مستشاري كريس جونسون السابق
، إنه
سيقسم تحت القسم أنه حذر
رئيس الوزراء من أن الحزب في الحديقة رقم
10 أثناء الإغلاق سوف
يخالف القواعد التي ينفيها جونسون ،
ولكن إذا كان هذا صحيحًا ، فهذا يعني أن جونسون
قد ضلل البرلمان و  يمكن أن ينهي
رئاسته للوزراء الآن ، ضع في اعتبارك
بالطبع أنه لا يوجد حب ضائع بين
كامينغز وجونسون منذ الحكومة اليسارية السابقة ،
ولكن تم طرد جونسون من أي وقت مضى
بسبب الكذب قبل
الإجابة بنعم في عام 2004 ، جلس جونسون
لظهوره وكأنه يكذب بسبب مزاعم
عندما كان وزيرا للمعارضة
، وفي عام 1988 ، تم فصله
من جريدة التايمز لتلفيقه
اقتباس وهو نقد تبعه
طوال حياته العامة
العام الماضي كتب قادة ما لا يقل عن
ستة أحزاب معارضة في بيت
المشاعات.  خطاب يتهم
جونسون بالفشل المستمر في الصدق
مع الحقائق ولكن اتهامات
بالكذب ويدعوه إلى الدقة.  Ign لم
تكن أبدًا أعلى صوتًا مما هي عليه الآن ،
فلماذا يكون تضليل البرلمان هو
النهاية المهنية لجونسون
إذا ثبت أن وزيرًا كذب على
البرلمان من المتوقع أن يستقيل أو
يُقال الآن ، لا يستطيع رئيس الوزراء
تكديس نفسه هكذا  كان من المتوقع أن
يستقيل مع القوة الكاملة للبرلمان الذي
يضغط عليه للقيام بذلك
ينص القانون الوزاري أيضًا على أن
الوزراء يجب أن يكونوا صادقين ولكن الأمر
متروك في النهاية لرئيس الوزراء أن
يأمر بإجراء تحقيق أو إنفاذ
القانون ، لذلك من العدل أن نفترض  أن
رئيس الوزراء ليس في عجلة من أمره
للتحقيق مع نفسه ،
ربما تعلم أن نواب بريطانيين
لا يستطيعون اتهام بعضهم البعض بالكذب في
منزل المشاع ، أما خادم فجر العمال
فقد طُرد لفترة وجيزة من
منزل المشاع لقوله ذلك
لقد كذب رئيس الوزراء على المنزل
والبلد مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
لذا يُقال إنه من الأسهل معاقبة
شخص يسمي النائب كاذبًا من
النائب الذي ربما يكون قد كذب لأن
ذلك أصعب.  ليثبت